Trascrizione: Piero Cavallo
Revisore: Deborah Sciacero
Io sono qua.
Da sola.
Sul palco del TEDx Reggio Emilia
e ho paura.
Ho paura di deludervi,
di non esserne all’altezza.
Alzi la mano chi mi invidia!
Qualcuno vuole essere al mio posto?
Ma mi sono fatta coraggio,
perché l’idea
che voglio condividere con voi
è più importante
della mia paura di essere qui, esposta
e quindi in qualche modo diversa da voi.
Io sono Arianna, ho 25 anni
e nel 2019 ho fondato Novis Games,
una start up innovativa ad impatto sociale
che si occupa di gaming e accessibilità.
Ho fondato Novis insieme a Dario,
il mio primissimo socio
e siamo partiti
da uno stage universitario della SEI,
una scuola di imprenditoria di Torino.
Con il nostro team, siamo partiti
proprio dalla nostra esperienza di sport
per provare ad immaginarci
un modo nuovo di interagire con gli altri
utilizzando la tecnologia
per superare le barriere.
E quasi come un esperimento mentale
ci è sorta una domanda.
Come sarebbe giocare ad un videogioco
senza utilizzare gli occhi?
Provate a immaginare.
Provate a chiuderli.
Con Novis Games stiamo immaginando
un nuovo modo di giocare
basato su audio e tatto
per superare la barriera della vista
e permettere a tutti di superare
anche la barriera della distanza,
di genere, della diversità,
della disabilità.
Una piattaforma di gaming
completamente accessibile
a persone ipovedenti e non vedenti.
Quando parlo del progetto
sono coraggiosa, mi sento forte.
Ma lo sono sempre stata?
Assolutamente no.
E tante volte non lo sono nemmeno oggi.
Da bambina quando dovevo parlare in classe
di fronte ai miei compagni
mi sudavano tantissimo le mani
e, tra parentesi,
mi stanno sudando anche adesso.
Cioè se mi cade il microfono
sapete perché.
Mi sono fatta coraggio.
Perché...
Quanto fa paura essere l’unica bambina
che nell’intervallo a scuola
gioca a calcio con i maschi?
Io sono da sempre appassionata di sport,
tifosa sfegatata della squadra
della mia città, il Torino,
e a 12 anni ho convinto mia mamma
ad iscrivermi alla mia prima squadra
di calcio femminile.
Quella è stata la prima volta in cui
mi sono sentita vagamente coraggiosa
perché ho trovato il supporto del mio
avversario numero uno a Fifa, il mio papà,
e poi perché ammetto
non potevo proprio farne a meno.
Perché ve lo sto dicendo?
Perché poi mia mamma ha iniziato
a venirmi a vedere giocare
e soprattutto perché,
un paio di domeniche fa,
sono andata io a vedere lei
alla sua prima partita
di calcio a 7 femminile.
Eccola lì, in basso a sinistra.
È stata una piccola grande conquista
perché mai mi sarei immaginata
che lei avrebbe potuto fare
qualcosa di così lontano,
che vedeva così lontano anche da me,
uscendo dai suoi schemi.
Perché uscire dalla comfort zone
non è facile per nessuno.
Si tratta di giocare
su un terreno che non si conosce,
con regole completamente diverse.
Resto sullo sport.
Vi è mai capitato
che il vostro allenatore,
nel mio caso il mister,
vi provasse in campo in un ruolo diverso?
Di norma, quando il portiere gioca
la partitella con i compagni,
da centravanti,
oltre a sbloccare del potenziale
che non aveva mai avuto modo
di sperimentare,
riesce a capire
che cosa significa dover segnare.
E a quel punto,
quando torna nel suo ruolo,
è ancora più consapevole
di quello che deve fare
il suo lavoro: proteggere la porta.
Col tempo in campo,
e anche e soprattutto
con il team di Novis Games,
ho capito quanto è importante
riuscire ad immedesimarsi negli altri.
Riuscire a comunicare, ad ascoltare.
Le migliori squadre riescono
a far forza proprio sulla diversità
per sviluppare un progetto attraverso
punti di vista completamente opposti.
Nel nostro caso addirittura
punti di non vista.
Quanto fa paura..
essere l’unica donna nella stanza
e la più giovane.
A me è successo tantissime volte
con il mio progetto
davanti ad investitori,
collaboratori, aziende.
Bisogna avere coraggio, però.
Se dovessi parlare alla me stessa
di 3-4 anni fa mi direi:
“Non avere paura!”
“Ricordati che può essere
un’occasione in più per essere ricordata.”
Io ho avuto la fortuna di poter lavorare
in uno spazio di lavoro condiviso:
il Talent Garden, di Torino
dove il progetto è partito.
Oggi sono alla guida
di un team di 5 ragazzi
estremamente diversi tra loro.
Ma è proprio questa la nostra forza.
Tante volte bisogna sforzarsi però.
Fa paura il giudizio degli altri.
Abbiamo il terrore
di deludere le aspettative.
Ma non sto parlando
delle persone vicine a noi.
Delle persone lontane da noi,
delle persone più vicine.
La nostra famiglia, i nostri amici.
Abbiamo bisogno del loro supporto,
cerchiamo la loro fiducia.
Tante volte queste etichette sociali,
che cosa studi, che sport fai,
che persone frequenti,
tendono a limitarci,
a farci paura e a non permetterci
di esprimere il nostro potenziale.
La verità è che...
essere diversi non è sempre semplice.
Ci vuole coraggio.
Avevo paura quando a 14 anni
mi gridavano “lesbica”
con mia mamma seduta sugli spalti.
Mi ha fatto paura dover trovare un altro
lavoro e intanto continuare a studiare
perché il progetto
non pagava uno stipendio.
Mi ha fatto paura dover ammettere
alla mia famiglia che non avrei fatto
né medicina né giurisprudenza,
perché forse non faceva per me
o perché forse ancora non lo sapevo,
perché avevo appena finito la maturità
e mi ero lanciata con il paracadute.
Volevo iscrivermi ad economia
per fare qualcosa di mio,
qualcosa di molto rischioso forse,
ma qualcosa di vero, di autentico,
che mi rendesse felice.
Qualcosa di diverso.
Questo è il significato
che ha la parola “diversità”
anche all’interno del nostro progetto.
La disabilità visiva
può essere concepita come un limite
oppure come un’opportunità
per fare qualcosa di nuovo di bello,
di positivo per noi e per gli altri.
Questo concetto mi ha dato
una nuova direzione alla vita,
mi ha permesso di capire
quello che davvero mi rendeva felice.
Mi hanno colpito tantissimo
le parole del fondatore di Starbucks,
Howard Schultz.
Lui diceva che molto di ciò
che attribuiamo alla fortuna
non è affatto fortuna.
Si tratta di cogliere l’attimo
e accettare la responsabilità
per il proprio futuro.
Essere in grado di vedere
ciò che gli altri non vedono
e perseguire quella visione.
Bisogna avere il coraggio
di essere diversi
perché è proprio questo
che ci caratterizza,
che ci rende autentici,
che ci dà identità.
Bisogna sforzarsi di seguire
i nostri desideri, le nostre passioni,
di fare tutte quelle cose che innescano
una scintilla di curiosità
per avere più fiducia
in noi stessi e negli altri.
Per coinvolgere
e per lasciarci coinvolgere
da un profondo entusiasmo.
Entusiasmo però nel senso
più antico del termine.
Enthéos in greco, un Dio dentro.
Una forza sovrumana che si libera
quando troviamo
quella cosa per cui vale
davvero la pena lottare,
per cui vale la pena
avere massima fiducia.
E a quel punto,
ogni meta può essere raggiunta
e non c’è limite
che non possa essere superato.
Quel sentimento che a fine giornata sì,
forse ci fa sentire un po’ diversi, ma...
anche un po’ più coraggiosi.
Io sono qua.
Da sola.
Davanti a voi.
Ma non ho più paura.
Mi sono fatta coraggio perché l’idea
che volevo condividere con voi
è più importante,
mi dà la forza di esprimermi
e di essere me stessa.
Se è stato il mio essere diversa
ad avermi portata qui
sul palco del TEDx Reggio Emilia.
Sono fortunata ad esserlo.